my stepfather was he's passed on now he
was very um impulsive and aggressive
very like verbally mentally emotionally
abusive and then my mother who is still
with us and I don't want to drag my
mother but my mother I perceived her to
be more passive and wasn't as protective
of me as she should be and so I think I
either will attract a partner who brings
the sort of um overly masculine the the
rage element and then I become my mother
in that relationship or I attract a
partner who plays the role of my mother
and that awakens a shadow in me as well
where I become very rebellious and um I
I resist and and uh push against the
relationship from that angle um I'm so
amazed to hear are you in therapy yeah
I've been in therapy obviously for a
long long time